Murder has inspired documentaries, podcasts and even games.
But our obsession with these stories made us wonder
Are there certain traits or factors that make someone more likely to kill someone?
And are you capable of murder?
To begin with, have you ever thought about it?
This actually doesn't mean that much because it happens so often.
A survey of nearly 1,000 students showed that
76% of women and 91% of men have indicated one
vivid and memorable murderous thought.
Other reports show that men are around ten and women around three
have had murder fantasies in the past year.
Is your heart beating faster now?
Then you are probably safe :).
A study of 710,000 participants, has the normal heart rate of men
measured when they were eighteen years old
as a part of a military service test.
In the consecutive decades, the men with the lowest were normal heartbeats
39% more likely than the high normal heartbeat group to commit a violent crime.
Furthermore, another study found that a low heart rate
was linked to stalk behavior.
A study of murderers who plead 'not guilty',